compression is reducing the amount of
information but without in a sense
losing any of it
trying to compress it and shorten it in
such a way that you could in principle
recover the full information that you
started with but in terms of
transmitting you know over a network
it's gonna cost you less because you pay
per bit or per byte or whatever and if
you can get the number of bytes down
that you need to transmit to get
something across the wire then that
benefits everybody generally you'd
sometimes not compress because the
following drawback happens if you
compress something then you have to
decompress it to get back the full story
that decompression takes time at the
other end yeah you have to get a
computer on it saying this was
transmitted compressed because it saved
BJ bandwidth costs but now I'm at this
end and I want to see the real picture
I'm going to uncompress it so the nice
thing about not compressing if you don't
mind the amount of data is it's there at
the other end and it's instantly
processable your compressed data
essentially by looking for repeated
patterns and predictability and I think
if you take an example shall we say of a
text file something that repeats itself
over and over again with the stock buzz
phrases used over and over and over
again is going to be pretty compressible
if somebody writes a report that's got
the phrase meaningful and relevant
scenarios at this point in time going
forward then you take that out and it's
been used a thousand times and it drives
you mad and you make one copy of it at
the top of the file and that's maybe how
to know 50 characters 50 bytes and you
say I'm not gonna spend 50 bytes
repeating that phrase every time in this
report I'm going to compress it take one
copy and I've taken note of where it
occurs in the file it occurs at start
positions 2800 1500 and so on and you
can save a huge amount because those
numbers take 3 or 4 bytes
not after an odd buys every time
pictures are harder coming back to this
idea that what makes things compressible
is predictability then if you think
about a photograph some photographs you
could say do have predictable areas you
could take shall we say a photograph of
like on Microsoft Windows there's a
yellow desert island in the middle of a
Pacific Ocean with one green tree that's
easy because the Pacific is totally
smooth you've got thousands of blue
pixels you've got hundreds of yellow
pixels for the desert island a few
hundred more for the tree so you can
compress it not by sending every single
pixel individually but by saying there's
the sea there's the color blue there's a
thousand of those just replicate them
similarly for the desert island and the
tree so that's what I mean by the
element of predictability or common
areas inside a picture now the average
photo you take may be fairly simple if
it's an indoor photo with flat surfaces
but you imagine taking a photograph for
example of a sports car race or of an
impressionist picture with blobs of
painting all over all over the place you
know that's much more random and there
isn't a pattern that you can pick up on
to make it easily compressible you
basically have to take a deep breath and
Sam gonna have to transmit the whole
thing cuz I can't see any patterns in
here you were talking about these blue
pixels there may be a thousand blue
pixels
yeah but the computer still has to know
where to put every single one so how are
we saving time you still have to
transmit some minimal information as for
where to start laying these pixels out
on the screen you say start at
such-and-such a position and X Y you
know how wide the picture is I just blew
out 10,000 blue pixels and see how if
it's in what will you don't have to say
is here is the spec of the blue pixel
for position a thousand here is the same
spec for the blue pixel at position 2001
you don't need to do that
you just send the Specht once and say
replicate it 400 or whatever times well
I'm making it simpler than it is perhaps
one good example would be that JPEG
compression is very common has to be
done to be able to get photographs down
for size to uploading to sites like
Picasa and Flickr they're not going to
be happy having every single one of your
photos taking up 20 megabytes and being
utterly perfect they want to compress it
down to kilobytes and the problem is
that many particularly scenery and so on
is innately random enough looking that
it's not easy to compress so JPEG is an
example of a compression that goes by
the name of lossy when we discussed
earlier about compression in the text
case I put it to you that you could
always recover the exact file because
you've had your bus phrase all the
places it was replicated nothing to stop
you at the far end undoing all that and
building it back exactly as it was with
no loss in a photographic case you could
try and do that but you wouldn't get
much compression because there's no
predictability so what JPEG does is
basically says if you'll allow me to do
some really clever things I will try and
get more compression out of it but I may
make the edges of your picture look a
bit blurry and fuzzy as you magnify them
and it's doing it by all sorts of tricks
about dividing the picture up into
blocks and squares and saying well this
is almost the same green I'll use this
as an approximation it's never
recoverable exactly the way you've
started but you get a lot more
compression that way if you don't mind
an approximation and for people and the
human visual system looking at something
that can often be pretty good particular
on a screen compressing genius's in
there
limits and surely that surely this has a
limit there is a limit this is something
that's covered by a fascinating topic
called information theory information
theory will tell you what is called the
entropy limit now many viewers of this
video will have heard of entropy and
will freeze solid because they were
taught it in physics and chemistry right
as a computer scientist let and the next
chemist let me tell you learning about
entry is a lot easier from a computer
science standpoint no question about it
you can workout for example what's the
minimum number of bits I need to
transmit and in piece of information in
a lossless way let's concentrate on that
what's the minimum number of bits I can
get away with and
what happens if I send one zero one and
there are two errors in there not just
one the errors just so happen we've got
far too many machines here to fit inside
this space